Você sabia que daqui uns anos as
superbactérias podem matar mais gente do
que o câncer? Pois é, olha só essa
notícia assustadora que acabou de sair.
Até 2050, essas bactérias resistentes
podem causar 10 milhões de mortes por
ano no mundo todo. E sabe por quê?
Porque a gente vem usando antibiótico de
forma errada há décadas. toma
antibiótico para qualquer coisa, não
completa o tratamento, usa em excesso na
agropecuária, contamina o meio ambiente
com resíduos e o resultado, as bactérias
estão ficando cada vez mais espertas e
resistentes. Veja bem, quando você toma
antibiótico sem necessidade ou para de
tomar antes da hora, você não mata todas
as bactérias, as mais fortes sobrevivem
e se multiplicam. Aí quando você
realmente precisa do antibiótico, ele já
não funciona mais. E o pior, isso não
acontece só com você, acontece no mundo
inteiro. É uma pandemia silenciosa que
tá avançando enquanto a gente não
percebe. Então, pensa comigo, só usa
antibiótico quando o médico realmente
prescrever, completa o tratamento
direitinho e nunca se automedica. Essa
conscientização pode salvar muitas vidas
no futuro.